there's something really ugly developing
that I want to talk about and it has to
do with two people it has to do with our
friend Ana Kasparian over at the young
turks and it also has to do with 2020
candidate Tulsi Gabbard and it kind of
also has to do with cults of personality
which I've talked about before I've
talked about how these cults of
personality can develop around
politicians and generally it's just not
good spirited enthusiastic support of
candidates that you think will be good
for America that's great we want that we
want people to be engaged we want people
advocating for people in policies that
they think are going to bring positive
change who could possibly criticize that
engaging in a respectful and sort of
issues oriented debate even if there are
strong disagreements that's great I'm
all for it it's what I do
this show is built around that idea but
when the behavior starts to become
obsessive and it turns into a cult of
personality generally speaking it's bad
and we should call it out when that's
going on we saw this and we still see it
around Donald Trump and his followers
there's a serious cult of personality
around Donald Trump and you can often
tell because when you criticize Trump
policy the blowback from his supporters
is ad hominem it's talking points and
memes and personal attacks and insults
there's no doubt that there was a sort
of cult of personality around george w
bush it's not just the right there are a
cult of personality around people that
are ostensibly on the left if you go
back to the 2016 election Jill Stein I
would criticize Jill Stein on issues and
the blowback would be I'm an
establishment shill smearing Jill Stein
I'm a Jew who can't see the truth like
Jill Stein is able to all of this stuff
there was a slight cult of personality
around Bernie in 2016 now not all Bernie
supporters in fact most did not sort of
support Bernie in this way I was a
Bernie supporter in 2016 but there was
this enclave of the sort of Bernie or
bust movement that had a component of
that toxic cult of personality so these
cults exist on the left they exist
on the right and right now I'm seeing it
with tulsi gabbard every time I critique
tulsi gabbard
the level of vitriol and toxicity that
is in the comments and reactions is
notable attacks against me claims that
I'm smearing without actually refuting
any of the assertions that I make
factually so I was really interested
when last week ana kasparian from The
Young Turks did an episode of no filter
where she has previously critiqued and
analyzed multiple 20/20 candidates she
did a segment about Tulsi Gabbard the
segment was good I tweeted the segment
it was filled with fact-based critiques
as ana kasparian saw them based on
things that Tulsi Gabbard has said or
things that she's done or based on how
she voted there were no ad homonyms from
ana there were no smears the video got
mostly dislikes more dislikes than likes
and it got a ton ton ton of comments
that are just disgusting stuff like
Ana's a hack she's spewing propaganda
she's an aborted three-year-old this is
an attack on Tulsi Ana's not really
progressive anna loves isis I could go
on just telling you the stuff that was
said but you probably get the idea so
far nothing is surprising okay this is
we've seen this around a tulsi gabbard
since she announced her candidacy so the
next thing that happens is that our
friend Jen huger from The Young Turks
interviews Tulsi Gabbard in the young
turks studio a few days after Anna's
video is put out and it's notable that
Ana isn't part of the interview Jenk is
interviewing Tulsi Gabbard Ana has been
part of other interviews that TYT has
done with 20/20 contenders and
politicians who visit their studio but
Ana's not there and this leads to even
more smears of ana by toasting avid
supporters ana is bad because she
refused to participate in the interview
with Tulsi Gabbard and it turns out that
Tulsi Gabbard presumably as a result of
the video Ana did last week said that
Tulsi would not participate in the
interview if Ana
participates that Ana should not be part
of the interview with tulsi gabbard
Ana followed up about this and actually
said the following in a reaction video
yesterday take a look although I would
have loved to ask Gabbard about the
issues raised in my previous episode of
no filter I was informed by her camp
that I would not be part of the
interview she had with TYT
last Friday it was surprising and a very
surprising demand considering no other
candidate had done the same regardless
of how critical I've been about their
positions in the past I've said multiple
times that true leaders put themselves
in uncomfortable positions when it's the
right thing to do and answering the
questions I had was the right thing to
do
Jake you ever conducted a great
interview and I highly recommend you all
check out the full conversation on t
Whitey's YouTube page but to set the
record straight for those who think I
ran from that interview understand that
I was in the same room watching as it
took place it was the first time any
politician walked into my home and told
me that I wasn't allowed to do my job so
you can disagree with my analysis you
can have a different perspective but you
can't argue that I smeared her without
providing a single example of me
fabricating anything not super
empowering of women for Telsey to say
that woman who criticized me she can't
ask me any questions when I'm there or
I'm not participating so this is not
about Ana's perfect Ana's right I agree
with Ana about some things I disagree
about others I've known her for many
years at this point and I have a sense
of her politics and her mo this is not
about this is the person whose politics
I'm 100% in line with although we have a
lot of points of agreement this is about
unfair smears that are examples of when
the left starts to eat itself and the
toxic cult of personality that exists
around tulsi gabbard now I'm sure that
if the tulsi campaign were to give a
statement about this and maybe they will
I don't know my guess is they would say
oh well you know there it was there were
time constraints and tulsi knows jenk
and they have a history already so we
felt it would be
better for a one-on-one interview it
wasn't anything against Anna we just
felt that it would be a bad interview
best handled as a one-on-one whatever
this is lame the toxic and angry
followers around tulsi gabbard
attacking anna viciously are disgusting
and ali every element of this absolutely
stinks and this is exactly the type of
thing that I talk about when I talk
about cults of personality when I talk
about arguments that aren't really
arguments attacking the messengers and
calling people chills and smears when
they are simply saying this is what the
person said and this is my
interpretation of that and everything
about this stinks and this is the type
of stuff that will lead to Donald Trump
being reelected Trump being reelected
won't just be because Tull sees
followers attack Tana okay I'm not being
myopic or childish in that way but this
type of thing developing around a
particular candidate it's just not good
for the left and if the number one
priority is removing Donald Trump from
office this is not the way to do it this
is part of a big bigger picture
that is going to make it not happen and
give us four more years of Donald Trump
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description i have listened to
blinkie's books about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it you
can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month go to blink is calm slash Pakman
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n